you know when you're faced with the
resounding humiliation that exposes how
badly you messed up the news you got two
options a admit your mistakes and learn
from them be circle the wagons and dig a
deeper grave guess what the media chose
what would you have had the media do
over the past two years so we've
reported on horse farms in Kentucky are
done investigations and out maybe eating
tree bark would lower our cholesterol
what would you have had us do I would
have read that story about tree bark so
let's compare this is Rachel Maddow from
last week
Brendon van gock my favorite name in the
whole Trump Russia probe honestly if
there wasn't a person involved in this
investigation named Brendan van gock
you'd have to invent one here's her now
in 1974 Leon Jaworski was the special
prosecutor who was investigating
Watergate and related issues within the
Nixon administration first special
prosecutor of course had been Archibald
Cox so without Russia she's reduced to
doing a history class for shut-ins she's
one month from scribbling helped me on a
chalkboard next week she'll be saying
this we're really freakin old I mean in
cable news years we're like a thousand
we're like great uncle Pete who's always
falling asleep and the Thanksgiving
mashed potatoes right we are a longfin
eel still swimming around New Zealand
ready to embark on the next phase of its
mysterious fish life after the age of
100 yeah meanwhile CNN honcho Jeff
Zucker excuses his guilt saying we are
not investigators we are journalists so
he admits his anchors or at least
stenographers not people capable of
ferreting out facts why work when Media
Matters can fit your script onto one
sheet but that doesn't explain why they
climbed into bed with Michael a vanetti
as he tried to destroy an innocent man
now he's been arrested and one of CNN's
former legal analysts may have been
involved I call it a bad week for CNN
but it's just another week for CNN it'd
be nice to see some introspection from
the media maybe ask themselves how do we
fall for this and did we play a role in
fooling others
but they can't because there's profit in
this narrative a narrative that's so
division that could have destroyed a
country by branding a president a
Russian spy they didn't care they still
don't the problem is they got caught but
I'm worried what do these people do when
they've driven their profession into the
ground
there's always vaudeville songs that
made this is my favorite part I would
have to be Archie we could use a man
like always good to have a back-up plan
it seems in a defensive mode Dana but
they've got a plan they do what is it
okay two things that they're gonna go
after one they will say that bill Barr
is compromised because Moeller did not
make a decision on obstruction though as
Andy McCarthy points out that was his
job right what did we pay you for your
job as a prosecutor is to make a
decision you didn't even do that so now
Jerry Nadler and other Democrats are
going to be able to say bar can we see
you please Merle er could we see you
please can you come up here and explain
to us how you were supposed to have an
apolitical
report and now it's totally compromised
because you let a political appointee
decide that President Trump is not
guilty of obstruction and that's exactly
where they are heading you heard it here
first you don't have to watch the other
channels for don't watch the other
channels Jesse isn't really the media
that eats deep State the the Morning Joe
clip you played at the top it's a straw
man argument we're not saying yeah I
want you to report on horse farms in
Kentucky just report the story fairly
and report it from both sides you can
still report on the Russia collusion
investigation but look around you don't
just look on one side of the story
because that's what Fox did and then we
benefited from that I think what's going
to happen now and you saw the ratings
last night the ratings for Fox were
astronomical and the ratings for CNN
lower than usual and MS
BC really really soft there's gonna be a
hangover I think you said at the top
people are gonna feel deceived if I'll
reviewer I would feel misled and you
know when you feel like you put all your
eggs in one basket and then it doesn't
deliver you're gonna take a little break
from TV yeah you're not gonna watch TV
for a little while I think a lot of
Republicans stopped watching TV after
Romney lost because people I media told
them that Romney was gonna win in a huge
landslide and when that didn't happen
they tuned out for a couple months and
that's what you'll see for the rest of
the press 1 why is it so hard just to
say hey we got it wrong well I'm still
waiting because actually I thought what
Jeff Zucker said was on target and
reporters don't have subpoena power we
don't have people that are on air like a
John Brennan no hang on the question was
about the media in general and about
puled surprises that went to the New
York Times The Washington Post and all
of a sudden you see per se what kind of
why was these where were these awards
given to these journalists when in fact
here's the finding of the Muller special
counsel but in fact the media doesn't
have the power to put people in jail to
investigate a foreign power trying to
subvert an American election that's
something that's done by people in power
and the journalists job is to report on
that and say you said a value on report
they have to vet that course but Jesse
you said no attention to the contrary
said effects coming from the Trump
administration effect to the contrary we
put Trump on TV every day saying no
collusion witch-hunt and all those deep
state that was MSNBC investigate the
dossier did they investigate the straw
texts do they invest as much as what he
did oh there are some responsible
journalists I saw like ABC I think his
name is Terry Moran who said you know
all of these people who came forward and
said all of these things like Brennan
especially and you go through the list
of Democratic operatives masking
themselves as intelligence officials who
have accused the president of treason he
is now said I'm going to push back
against all these people and demand more
evidence and so I hope more people
follow this honest reporters lead and
don't just take whatever the Democrats
we see they're hiding Adam Schiff and
all of these guys hi
the cloak of having some sort of valued
intelligence that the rest of us don't
have and it turned out to be a lie